dans le cadre de l'opération premières
pages ce mercredi 12 octobre village
corail un livre intitulé bienvenue petit
bébé a été offert à près de 2000
familles ayant accueilli un enfant en
2015 une action de sensibilisation à la
lecture dès le plus jeune âge initié par
l'état à laquelle participe le
département depuis cinq ans si le
conseil départemental
nous sommes aux côtés des services de
l'état c'est parce que nous estimons feu
il y a deux objectifs dans l'opération
premières pages
l'éducation c'est la famille qui voit là
donner l'instruction
c'est l'éclat la doit à chaque citoyen
est donc recommencer à refaire
d'éducation dans la maison il faut que
le baron samedi
cette opération
maman papa un livre avec est tout petit
à la naissance ensuite la première année
c'est une opération accor livres ont
retenu cette année est celui de jacques
lutter aux éditions orphie traduit en
créole par céline huet un livre
autobiographique pour souhaiter la
bienvenue à son fils c'est en fait une
discussion entre le papa et le bébé
avant la venue effective l'accouchement
du petit garçon donc ces voix là c'est
les premiers relation qui se crée qui se
tissent entre le papa et l'enfant et la
maman en fin de dans ce moment qu'est la
grossesse la découverte partager un
livre idiome soir qui crée un lien
privilégié entre enfants et parents
donc on avait tous les soirs poussant
d'ordre du conseil importants comme la
russie à l'aide un peu où on a le
l'éducation donnée à notre enfant mais
aussi bien la succession s'avoue par les
livres dont l'école aussi mais à la
maison nous on a toujours eu des deux
mois j'ai été élevé avec des riffs mais
j'adorais la lecture donc je souhaite
transmettre sans mes enfants
et c'est bien c'est que ce livre sont en
créole son avenir maternelle est à la
maison on parle de créole et français
l'opération qu'on partage contribuer à
pallier à la carence éducative alors que
près des pensées de personnes sont en
situation d'illettrisme est là
mieux